Okay.
So last time we came across a new idea,
although it wasn't really new for a lot of you,
and that was the idea of Nash
equilibrium.
What I wanted to do today is discuss Nash Equilibrium,
see how we find that equilibrium in some rather simple examples.
And then in the second half of today,
I want to look at an application where we actually have some fun and play a
game.
What does,
I hope it's fun.
All right,
but it starts by putting down a formal definition.
We only used are all the informal one last week.
Uh,
so here's a fun one.
A strategy profile.
Remember profile is one strategy for each player.
So it's going to be s one star,
two star,
all the way out to s Amstar if there are end players playing the game.
So this profile is a nash equilibrium and I'm just gonna write m e in this
class,
the Nash equilibrium from now on.
If
for each I used to be each player,
I have a choice.
So choice.
Here is s I start,
I as part of that profile is a best response
is the best response
to [inaudible]
the other players choices,
the other players
choices.
What's the other players choices here?
Oh s minus side style.
So everyone is playing a best response to everyone else,
right?
No,
this is by far the most commonly used solution concepts in game theory.
So those of you who are interviewing from Mckinsey or something,
you're going to find that they're going to expect you to know what this is.
All right,
so one reason for knowing what it is is because it's in the textbooks.
It's going to be used in lots of applications is going to use in your Mckinsey
interview.
That's not a very good reason,
right?
And I certainly don't want you to jump to the conclusion that now we've got to
nash equilibrium.
Everything we've done up to now is somehow someone at some sense irrelevant.
That's not the case.
It's not always going to be the case that people always play a nash equilibrium.
For example,
when we played the numbers game,
the game,
when you chose a number we've already discussed last week or last time,
that the equilibrium in that game is for everyone to choose one.
But when we actually played the game,
uh,
the average was much higher than that.
The average is about 13.
It is true that when we paid it repeatedly,
it seemed to converge towards one,
but the play of the game when we played at just one shop first time wasn't a
Nash Equilibrium,
right?
So we shouldn't have formed the mistake of thinking people always play Nash
equilibrium or people if they're rational for Nash equilibrium.
But neither of those statements are true.
Nevertheless,
there are some good reasons,
but thinking about Nash equilibrium,
other than the fact it's used other people,
and let's talk about those a bet.
So what have I done to motivations here?
Yeah.
All right.
The first motivation we already discussed last time.
In fact,
somebody in the audience mentioned it and it's the idea of no regrets.
Okay.
So what does this idea it says,
suppose we're looking at a nash equilibrium.
If we hold the strategies of everyone else fixed,
no individual,
I has an incentive to deviate to move away.
All right?
Say it again.
Holding everyone else's actions fixed.
No individual has an incentive to move away and letting me be a little bit more
careful here.
No individual has any strict incentive to move away.
All right,
we'll see that that actually matters,
right?
So no individual can do strictly better by moving away.
All right?
No individual
can do strictly
strictly batter
by Dva.
Sing.
Hold on,
holding everyone else fixed.
All
right?
So why would I call that?
And they regret it means having played the game.
Suppose you did in fact play a Nash equilibrium and then you look back at what
you've done and now you know what everyone else has done and you say,
do I regret my actions?
And the answer is no.
I don't regret my actions because I did the best I could give them what they
did.
All right?
So that seems like a fairly important,
so central idea for why we should care about Nash equilibrium.
Here's a second idea and we'll see others arise in the course of today.
The second idea is that a nash equilibrium can be thought of as so fulfilling
beliefs.
So in the last week or so,
we've talked a fair amount about beliefs.
If I believe the goalkeeper is going to die of this way,
I should shoot that way and so on.
All right?
But of course we didn't talk about any beliefs in particular these beliefs.
I believe that if everyone in the game believe that everyone else is going to
play their part of a particular Nash Equilibrium,
then everyone will in fact play their part
about Nash equilibrium.
All right.
Now why?
Why?
Why is it the case that everyone believes that everyone else is playing their
part of that,
of this particular Nash Equilibrium,
but that Sofa fatigue and people actually will play that.
Why is that the case?
Anybody?
Yeah.
Can we,
can we get this guy in red?
Yep.
Does your own Nash Equilibrium Strategy is the best response against those?
Cause I played exactly.
So it's,
it's really,
it's almost a repeat of the first thing.
If I think everyone else is going to play that,
particularly if I,
if I think players two through n are going to play [inaudible] star through as
Enstar,
then by definition my best response is to play us one star.
So I will in fact pay my part of the Nash Equilibrium.
Right?
Good,
good.
All right.
So as part of the definition,
you can see these are self fulfilling beliefs.
Let's just remind ourselves how that arose in the example we looked at at the
end last time.
I'm not going to go back and reanalyze it by a hundred.
Sort of make sure that we followed it.
So we had this Patria last time
in the,
in the partnership game in which people were choosing effort levels
and this,
this line was the best response for player one as a function of player two's
choice.
And this lion was the best response of player to uh,
as a function of player once choice.
All right.
There's the pitch we saw last time and let's just look at how there's no secret
here.
What the Nash Equilibrium is.
Nash equilibrium is where the lines cross.
But let's just see how it maps up to those,
those two motivations we've got said.
So how about self fulfilling beliefs?
Well,
if player,
sorry,
I put one management tool.
If play a one believes that player two is going to choose this strategy,
then play a one should choose this strategy.
Play one thing to play a tourist using this strategy.
Then player one should choose this strategy.
Play one thing to play a Tuesdays in this strategy than prayer.
One should do this draft and so on.
That's what it means to be a best response.
But if player one thing to play a two is playing exactly
her Nash Strategy,
then play a one's best response is to respond by playing his na strategy.
And conversely,
if player two things play a one is playing his nash strategy,
then play a tos.
Best response indeed is to play her math strategy.
All right?
So you can see that as self fulfilling belief.
If both people think that's what's going to happen,
that is indeed what's going to happen.
All right,
how about the idea of no regrets?
So here's player one.
She wakes up the next morning.
I was,
he was,
he wasn't.
He wakes up the next morning and he says,
I chose s one star.
Do I regret this?
Well now he knows what play a to chose by a tutors as two star and he says,
no,
that's the best I could have done given the player to didn't factories as to
star.
I have no regrets about shooting us one star.
That in fact was my best response and there's just,
that wouldn't be true.
It's another outcome.
So for example,
if player,
what if player one had chosen s one star but play a to a chosen some other
strategy,
let's say s two prime,
then play a one would have regrets,
might play.
One would wake up the next morning and say,
I thought player one was going to play us to star.
In fact,
she chose us to prime.
I regret having chosen s one star.
I would have rather chosen as one prime only at the Nash equilibrium are the no
regrets.
Right?
Everyone okay with that?
This is just revisiting really what we did last time and underlining these
points.
All right,
so I want to spend quite a lot of time today just getting used to the idea of
Nash Equilibrium and trying to find now she could ever,
am I going to turn off that projector that's in the way that I can.
Okay.
Is that going to upset the lights a lot?
All right.
So,
okay,
so uh,
what I want to do is I want to look at some very simple games with a small
number of players to start with and a small number of strategies and I want us
to get used to how we would find Nash Equilibria in those simple gains.
Okay.
We'll start slowly and then we'll get a little faster.
So let's start with this game.
Very simple game with two players.
Each player has three strategies.
I'm not going to motivate this game.
It's just some random game play.
A one can choose up,
middle or down and play.
A two can choose left center and right and the payoffs are as follows,
zero four (405) 340-0453 again,
three five
three five and six six
all right,
so we can discuss.
We,
if,
if we had more time we could actually play this game,
but it isn't politically exciting games.
Let's,
let's leave our playing for later and instead let's try and figure out what are
the Nash Equilibria in this game and how are we going to go about finding the
right and the way we're going to go out.
Finding them is going to mimic what we did last time.
Last time we had a more complicated game and which was two players with a
containment strategies.
And what we did was we figured out play a one's best responses and play a tos
best responses,
pay a one's best response to what player two's doing and play a tos best
response to what player one's doing.
And then we looked where they coincided and that was the Nash Equilibrium.
And we're going to do exactly the same in this simple game here.
So we're going to start off by figuring out what play one's best response looks
like.
All right,
so in particular,
what would be player ones best response
if player to chooses left or be play one's best response if player to chooses
left.
Let's get the mics up so I can sort of,
uh,
um,
challenge people.
Anybody not at not such a hard question.
Do you want it to try that?
The woman in the middle?
Uh,
who's closer to the room?
Yeah.
Mm.
Okay.
So,
so,
uh,
play a one's best response in this case is middle.
All right?
Because four is bigger than zero and is bigger than three.
Alright,
so to more cat facts,
what will we can do is let's put a circle like in Green as put a circle
round that round that for,
okay.
Hi.
Not Hard,
right?
It's nice to do it again.
What does play a one's best response
player to choose this center?
What does play a one's best response?
If player to choose a sentence,
get somebody on the other side.
Uh,
uh,
so what do you should feel free to cold call somebody here?
So,
uh,
just,
how about Calico Cabot Cochran and the guy with the Yale football shirt on?
Here we go up.
All right.
So [inaudible] is the correct answer.
So say one triumph for Yale at war.
Okay.
So,
all right,
so,
so four is bigger than three.
Bigger than zero.
All right,
so good.
Thank you.
All right,
and uh,
Ali,
why don't you do the same,
why don't you call,
call somebody who's going to tell me what's the best response for player one?
Uh,
to uh,
to write
down.
Down.
Okay.
So,
uh,
best response is down because six is bigger than five,
which is bigger than five.
Six is bigger than five.
Okay.
All right.
So what we've done here is we've found player one's best response to left center
and best response to right and in passing,
notice that each of player one strategies is the best response to something.
So nothing would be knocked out by our domination arguments here and nothing
would be knocked out.
Clay are never a best response arguments yet for player one.
Okay?
Okay,
let's do the same.
The play too.
So why don't I keep the Mike's doing some cold calling.
So when they don't you want to cold call somebody at the back to tell me what is
play a tos best response against up.
Let's play a tos.
Best response against up.
It's probably in there.
Yeah.
Um,
left.
All right.
So,
so the gentleman in blue says left because four is bigger than three is bigger
than zero.
Let's uh,
switch colors and switch 'em polygons and uh,
you know,
put squares around these.
Okay.
All right.
I don't insist on the circles and the squares and you have a thing back second
that you can do that too.
Whatever you want.
All right.
What's,
uh,
what's play a tune?
It's right in here.
The answer is,
the answer was that the best response was left.
All right.
And play a twos best response to middle.
Uh,
so much you don't end up doing to grab somebody over there,
center it out center.
All right.
Because,
because four is bigger than through to bigger than zero.
So that sensor and then my color coding,
like which me,
it gives me a square here.
And finally,
uh,
play a tos best response to down and turn away.
Let's grab somebody.
Ah,
laugh.
I'm sorry.
Right now he writes.
Okay,
good.
Good cause because six is bigger than five again.
Okay.
So,
so here we go.
All right.
So what we've done now is found play a one's best response function.
That was just the analog of finding the best response line we did here.
Here we drew it as a straight line and whites,
but we could have drawn it as a sequence of little circles in green.
It would have looked like this,
right?
And same idea.
We're not going to do the whole thing,
right?
It'll be a whole bunch of circles looking like this.
And then we found play a tos best response for each choice of player one.
And we used pink rectangles and that's the same ideas we did over here.
Here.
We did it in a continuous strategies in Calc,
but it's the same idea.
So imagine I'm drawing lots of pink rectangles and again,
I'm not going to do it,
but you can do it in your notes.
Okay.
All right.
Same basic idea.
And just as the Nash equilibrium must be where these best response lines
coincided here because that's the point at which each player is playing a best
response to each other.
All right,
so the Nash equilibrium over here is drum roll tide on a,
on a cold call.
Somebody you want a coke,
just grab somebody in the row behind you or something or whatever.
Yeah.
Anybody,
anybody?
All right?
Yeah,
yeah,
I think you were in Italia Italia soccer shirt you get,
you're going to get picked on.
So,
so,
okay,
so what's the Nash Equilibrium here?
Uh,
the bottom right's where?
All right,
so the downright scratch the Nash Equilibrium here is no prizes in a World Cup
for that one is,
is downright.
All right.
All right,
so why is that the Nash Equilibrium?
Because at that point play a one is playing a best response to play a two and
play a two is playing our best pumps to play a one right now I want to try and
convince you,
particularly those of you who are worried by the homework assignment,
that that was not rocket science.
Right?
Right.
It's not hard to find that equilibrium games.
All right,
what didn't take us very long and we went pretty slow actually.
Alright,
so let's look at another example.
Oh,
before I do,
there was just before I leave this game,
make one of the remark notice in this game that are each strategy of player one
is the best response to something and each strategy of player two is the best
responses on thing.
So how we use the methods of the earlier on the class as to say if do eating
Donnie his strategies or reading strategies that are never a best response.
We've gotten nowhere in this game.
All right,
all right,
so now she couldn't run.
It goes a little further in narrowing down our predictions,
but we also learn something from that we all,
you'd lost time and in the last few weeks that rationality or even mutual
knowledge of rationality or even common knowledge of rationality couldn't really
get as much further than deleting dominated strategies or if you like deleting
strategists that are never the best responses.
All right,
so here we've concluded that the Nash Equilibrium of this game is downright a
very particular prediction.
But notice a perfectly rational player could here could choose middle.
The reason they could choose middle player,
one could choose middle.
It's is could be that if they say rationally they should choose middle because
they think by a two is choosing left and they'd say,
you say,
well why would you think play a two is gonna choose left?
And I'll play a one can say,
I think player two is going to choose left because player to thinks I'm going to
play up.
And then you say,
but how could play a to possibly think that you're going to play up and and pay
one would you say,
I think play a two things.
I'm going to play up because player two things that I think that he's going to
play center and then you could say how good play a two pump,
etc.
Etc.
And you could see you could work us off round little cycle that nobody would be
irrational to anything.
Everything will be perfectly well justified in terms of beliefs.
It's just we wouldn't have a nice uh,
fixed point who'd have a nice point where it's a simple arguments,
uh,
in case of downright play a one thinks it's okay to play down because he thinks
Tuesday pay.
Right and pay a two things to payment,
right?
Cause he thinks payer once in the bay down.
Right.
So just to,
just to underline what I'm saying,
rather messily that rationality and that,
that those kinds of arguments should not lead us to the conclusion that people
necessarily play Nash Equilibrium.
All right.
We good?
We need a little bit more.
You do it more than that.
Nevertheless,
we are going to focus on Nash equilibrium in the cost.
All right,
let's have a look at another example
and again,
we'll keep it,
keep it simple for now and we'll keep to a two player.
Three strategy game.
Oh middle down left center,
right.
And this time the payoffs are as follows.
0223431113
two zero zero zero three one zero s and eight zero s this is a slightly messier
game.
The numbers were really just whatever came into my head when I was writing it
down.
And once again,
we want to find out what's the Nash equilibrium is in this game.
And our method is exactly the same.
We're going to from each player,
figure out their best responses for each possible choice of the other player.
So rather than write out a thought,
let me just go straight to my green circles and red squares and,
uh,
let me get my makes up again.
All right,
so we can cold call people a bed.
All right.
Can I get the,
uh,
where's my,
where's the Michael.
Thank you.
All right.
So,
uh,
Ali do want just grab somebody and ask them what's the best response against the
left?
Okay.
Can Grab anybody.
What's the best ones?
Gonna say middle.
Middle.
Okay,
good,
good.
So middle is the best response against left because 11 is bigger than zero.
All right.
Uh,
murder than you to get to grab somebody.
What's the restaurant against center?
Middle.
Middle again,
because three is bigger than two is bigger than one.
And uh,
grab something at the back.
And some of the best responses against.
Right?
Anybody?
Just a dive in?
Yup.
Down.
Uh,
okay.
Dot.
Down.
Good.
All right.
And let's do the same for,
uh,
the column player.
So what's the colon players?
Uh,
uh,
la.
If I find somebody to take the guys two rows behind you is about to fall asleep
and ask him what's the best response to up,
um,
the best response would beach for which,
which player to play at sees what's what's player to best response for up?
Sorry,
I'm just going to pick on someone else's,
right.
What's the best response for a CNR or tired?
So C or are,
all right.
So this is a slightly more tricky one,
right?
The best response to up is either C or are,
this is why we've got you to sign this legal forms,
right?
Okay.
Best wants to op is either C or are the best response to middle.
Don't happen.
Yep.
Man.
Center is center.
Thank you.
And the best response to down.
Okay.
Left.
All right,
so the best ones to down is face left.
And here again,
it didn't take us very long.
We're getting quicker at this.
The Nash Equilibrium in this case is now she can,
let's go back to the guy who was asleep and uh,
give me an easier question this time.
So Nash equilibrium in this case is nash equilibrium would be,
uh,
the three two combinations,
but exactly.
Okay.
So the,
the,
the middle,
the Middle Center.
All right.
I noticed this is the Nash Equilibrium.
Why is it matter collaborate?
Because each player is playing a best response to each other,
right?
If I'm a player one,
and I think that player two is playing center,
I should play metal and one player too.
I think Pi wanted playing middle aged should play sensor.
If in fact we play this way,
neither person has any regrets.
Those they didn't do particularly well in this game in particular player one
would have liked to get this 11 on this eight.
All right.
But they don't regret that action because given that player to play center,
the best they could have got was three,
which they got by playing middle.
Right now,
just in passing in this game,
there's just in passing that best responses needn't be unique,
right?
Sometimes it can be a tie in your best response.
Okay.
That can happen.
All right,
so what don't we see?
We've seen out of financial equilibrium and clearly it's very closely related to
the idea of best response,
which is an idea we've been developing over the last week or so.
All right,
but let's go back.
Oh,
they're in the course and ask how does it relate to the idea of dominance,
right?
We already [inaudible].
This is really our third concept in this course,
right?
We had a concept about dominance.
We had a concert about best response and now we're at Nash equilibrium.
It's,
I think,
obvious how it relates to best response,
which when Bester Fontis coincide,
how about how it relates to dominoes?
Wow.
To do that,
let's go back.
We're going to do is
we're going to relate
nash equilibrium to idea
of dominance or don't of domination.
All right?
And to do that obvious place to start is to go back to a game that we've seen
before.
So here's a game where player one and player two are choosing Alpha and Beta,
and the payoffs are zero zero three minus one minus one three and one one.
All right?
So this is the game we saw the first time.
This is the prisoner's dilemma.
All right?
And we know in this game,
I'm not going to bother to cold call people for it.
We know in this game that Bita is dominated,
is strictly,
it's strictly dominated
by Alpha,
right?
It's like we learned the very first time,
Just to check.
All right?
So against Alpha,
uh,
against Alpha Alpha,
choosing Alpha gets you zero B to get to minus one against Bita.
Choosing Alpha gets you three bet against you.
One.
In either case,
Alpha is strictly better.
So Alpha Strip it on its feet.
And of course it's the same,
but the column player,
since the Games completely similar.
All right?
So now that's fine.
The Nash Equilibrium in this game,
I think we know what it's going to be.
All right,
but let's just do it in a sort of a slow away.
All right?
So,
uh,
the best response to Alpha must be alpha.
The best response to Bita must be alpha.
And for the column player,
the best response to Alpha,
we'll do it in pink,
was the best responders to Alpha must be Alpha and the best restaurants to Biesa
must be alpha.
Everyone okay with that?
And just kind of rushing it a bit because it's kind of obvious,
is that right?
Okay.
And so the Nash Equilibrium in this game,
I'm actually glad room is Alpha Alpha.
In other words,
it's what we would have arrived at how we just deleted strictly dominated
strategies.
And so here's a case where Alpha strictly dominates Bita and sure enough nash
equilibrium coincides.
It gives us the same answer.
Both people choose Alpha in this game.
All right?
So there's nothing,
there's no news here.
I'm just checking that we're not getting anything weird going on.
All right,
so let's ask me a bit more careful.
how do we know it's the case?
So I'm going to claim it to the case that no strictly dominated strategy.
In this case,
Bita,
no strictly dominated strategy could ever be played in an actual equilibrium.
So I,
I claim that that's a good thing,
right?
Because we want,
we want these ideas to coincide.
I claimed that no strictly dominated strategy could ever be played
internationally.
Equilibrium.
Why is that the case?
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a a guy,
okay.
Yeah.
Strictly dominated strategy isn't the best response to anything.
So it couldn't be the best response to,
to the net,
to their plan,
the Nash Equilibrium.
Good.
Very good.
So strictly dominated strategy is never a best prompts to anything in
particular.
The thing that dominates,
it always does better.
All right?
So in particular,
it can't be a best response to the thing being played in Nashik,
whatever.
All right?
So that's actually a good,
good proof that proves,
that knows strictly dominated strategy could ever be played in a national
[inaudible].
But now we have unfortunately a little wrinkle.
The wrinkle,
the wrinkle,
unfortunately is weekly domination is weak domination.
So we've argued if it was fairly easy to argue that no strictly dominated
strategy is ever going to reappear annoyingly in a nash equilibrium.
But unfortunately the same is not true about weekly donated strategies.
And in some sense you had a foreshadowing of this problem a little bit on the
homework assignment where you saw on one of the problem,
I think it was the second problem on the homework assignment,
that deleting weekly dominated strategies can lead you to do things that might
make you feel a little bit uneasy.
All right?
So we can donate week domination is really not such a secure notion as strict
domination.
And we'll see here as a trivial example of that in the game.
Here's a trivial example on an interesting example,
but it just makes the point.
So here's a two way to game play.
A one can choose up or down and play a two confused left or rights and the
payoffs are really trivial.
One one zero,
zero,
zero.
All right,
so let's figure out what the Nash Equilibrium is in this game.
And I'm not going to bother cold calling because it's,
it's too easy.
So,
uh,
the best response for player one player two players left is clear to shoes up.
And the best response of player one if player to choose his rights is,
well,
I,
the apple down,
we'll do right cause either way he gets or she gets zero.
So these are both best responses,
is that correct?
They're both restaurants is they both do equally well.
All right.
And uh,
conversely play,
uh,
to uh,
play a tos best response if play a one shoes is up,
is sure enough to choose left.
And that's kind of the answer we'd like to have.
But unfortunately,
when player one plays down,
play or two's best response is either left or right,
it makes no difference.
They get zero either way.
All right.
Okay.
So what are the national clever in this game?
What are the Nash Equilibrium in this game?
So notice,
first observation is there's more than one now she could ever in this game,
right?
We haven't seen that before.
All right.
There's a nash equilibrium with everybody in the room,
I think.
I hope thinks he's kind of the sensible prediction in this game.
All right.
In this game.
I think all of you,
I hope all of you,
if your player one would choose up and all of you have played,
two would choose left.
Is that right?
Is that correct?
I just make it,
it's hard to imagine coming up with an argument that wouldn't lead you to choose
up and left in this game.
All right?
However,
unfortunately,
unfortunately that isn't it.
This isn't the unfortunate upper left is a nash equilibrium,
but so is downright
right.
If play a two is choosing,
writes your best response weekly is to choose down if play a one is choosing
down play a tos best response weekly is to choose,
right?
All right,
and here we are here.
What this is,
uh,
arriving because of the definition of national it,
it,
it's,
it's a very definitely definition.
When we,
when we looked at the police didn't have in mind what is the definition we said
something isn't actually collaborate with each person that's playing the best
response to each other.
And we have seen that is no player has a strict incentive to deviate.
No pay.
I can do strictly better by moving away.
So here it down.
Rights play a one doesn't do strictly better,
it's just a tie.
If she moves away and play a two doesn't do strictly better.
If he moves away,
it's a tie.
He gets early either way.
So here we have something which is going to worry us going on in the course.
Sometimes we're getting not getting many,
many.
Now she put a right out.
So that's,
that's,
that's something which I shouldn't worry as well is it's a fact of life.
But in this case,
one of the Nash Equilibria seems silly,
right?
I mean if you,
if you,
if you went and tried to explain to your roommates and said,
I predict both of these outcomes in this game,
they'd laugh at you.
It's obvious in some sense that this has to be the sensible protection.
All right,
so just that sort of worrying notes before we move on.
Okay.
So this was pretty formal and kind of,
uh,
not very exciting so far.
So let's try and move on to something a little bit more fun.
Okay.
So what I want to do now is I want to get a different game.
Again,
we're going to try and find Nash equilibrium in this game,
but we're going to do more than that.
We're going to talk about the game of bed and a feature of this game,
which is uh,
to,
to distinguish it from what we've done so far is the game of went to look at
involves many players.
Although each player only has few strategies.
All right?
So I want to do is I want to convince you how to find an artist to discuss how
to find Nash Equilibria in the game,
which unlike these games,
it doesn't just have to players,
it has many players,
but fortunately not many strategist per player.
All right?
So let me use this board.
All right,
so this is going be called the investment
game
and we're going to play this game,
although not for real.
All right?
So the players in this game,
I was,
I just suggested the players are going to be you.
All right?
So everyone who was getting sleepy,
just looking at this kind of analysis should wake up.
Now.
You have to play.
All right?
And the strategies in this game,
a very simple strategy sense.
Well,
the strategy will turn.
It says each of you can choose between investing
nothing in a class,
project zero or
invest $10 alright,
I'm just gonna refer to investing.
Nothing as not investing.
Is that okay?
All right.
And it seems like a natural thing.
You're either going to invest $10 or nothing.
I you're not gonna Invest.
All right?
So that's the players.
And those are the strategies.
So as usual,
we're missing something we're missing are the payoffs.
Alright?
So here are the payoffs.
So the offs was follows.
If you don't invest,
if you do not invest,
I invest nothing,
then you'll pay off.
Is there?
All right,
so nothing ventured,
nothing gained,
right?
Natural thing,
But if you do invest,
yeah,
that's right.
If you invest $10,
remember each of you is gonna be investing $10 then your individual payoffs are
as follows.
Here's the good news.
You're going to get a profit of $5 where this isn't a work is you're going to
invest in $10 you'll make a gross profit of 15 minus the 10 year originally
invested for a net of five I don't understand,
right?
So a net profit to $5 net profit,
that's the good news.
But that requires
more than 90% of the class to invest
greater than equal to 90% of the class turn faster than if more than 90% of the
class invest,
you're going to make essentially 50% profit.
And unfortunately the bad news is you're going to lose your $10,
get nothing back,
right?
So this is a net loss
if fewer
than 90% of the class
in best.
All right?
I need a key here.
You're not allowed to talk to each other,
alright?
No communication in the class.
No hands evolves,
no secret winks,
right?
Nothing else.
All right.
Okay.
So everyone understand the game,
including up on the boat.
Everyone.
I'm sound the game.
All right?
So what I want you to do,
I should say,
first of all,
we can't play this game for real cause I cause there's something like 250 and
you want to,
I don't have that kind of cache line,
right?
Right.
So we're not pretend or playing this for real.
Okay.
Tell I'm playing with story.
All right?
So without communicating,
I want each of you to right on the corner of your notepad,
whether you're going to invest or not.
So you can write why.
If you're going to invest.
And M if you're not going to invest,
I discussed it with each other.
Just write down on the corner of your notepad.
Why?
If you're gonna invest an n,
if you're not going to,
don't,
don't discuss it guys.
I'm discuss it.
All right?
And now show,
show your neighbor what you did just so you can,
your neighbor can make he make you honest.
All right,
now.
Okay,
let's have a show of hands.
All right.
So what I want to do is I wonder,
I wonder how a show of hands,
everybody who invested,
everyone don't look around.
Just raise your hands.
Everyone who invested in everyone who didn't invest.
Oh,
that's more than 10% all right,
so let's do that again.
So everyone who invested raise their hands,
raise their hands and everyone who didn't invest raise their hands.
So I didn't know what that is.
Maybe it's about half and half.
So now I'm thinking we should play this game for real.
I want to just get some discussion going about this,
right?
What I want,
I'm going wanting to discuss this for a while.
There's lots to be said about this game.
Uh,
that'd be borrow that.
Can I borrow this?
All right,
so,
uh,
this guy.
Okay.
So what did you do?
I invest it.
And why did you invest?
Uh,
cause
I think I can lose $10.
All right.
All right,
so he's rich.
That's okay.
It's okay.
You can,
you can pay for lunch.
It's right.
That's all right.
All right.
Who didn't invest in it?
If it's a non investors?
Yeah.
So [inaudible] is one,
so,
okay,
so why didn't you invest?
Shout it out.
So we're going to hear,
I didn't invest because I,
because to make a profit,
there needs to be at least a two to one chance that every else,
that 90% invest our rise to take an expected profit.
Yeah.
You only get half back,
but you'd lose the whole thing.
I see.
Okay.
So you've been talking,
I've expected estimation.
Uh,
other reasons,
other reasons out there?
Uh,
what did,
what did you do?
I invested.
You're invested with it.
You know,
I'm,
I'm finding the sock is on the road.
Okay,
so you invested why B you stand to gain something.
I don't see why anybody would just not invest because they don't,
they would never get anything.
All right,
so,
so yeah.
Your name is Clayton.
So Clayton saying only by investing can I gain something here?
Not Investing.
It seems kind of,
you know,
it doesn't seem,
uh,
brave in some sense.
Anyone else?
Yeah.
Um,
it's basically the same game is the one one zero zero game in terms of both Nash
Equilibria.
Um,
but the payoffs aren't like the same scale.
and uh,
yeah,
you'd have to really risk averse not to invest.
So I thought people would be,
so you're investing I invest in,
yeah.
All right.
So let me,
let me give this to La for,
I struck the sound system here.
Okay.
So we've got different answers out.
If it did,
people can people hear each other's answers?
Abet?
Yup.
So we have lots of different views out here.
We have half the people investing and half the people are not investing roughly.
And I think you can make arguments either way.
All right,
so we'll come back to whether it's exactly the same as the game we just saw.
So the argument that a,
I'm sorry,
your name is Patrick made is it looks a lot like the game.
We still got four and we'll,
we'll,
we'll say it is related clearly.
It's right in one sentence,
which we'll discuss now.
So,
um,
tell me about,
I need this thing again.
Sorry.
So what are the Nash Equilibria in this game?
What are the Nash Equilibria in this game?
All right.
We can.
We have a course on his phone message,
but in the meantime,
what are the,
what are the Nash Equilibrium?
This game?
Yeah.
Let me get the woman up here yet.
Yep.
No one invests and everyone's happy that they didn't lose anything or everyone
invests in.
Everyone's happy.
Good,
good,
so I've forgotten your name.
It's a case saying that there are two now she Culebra and with apologies to
shoot.
I'm going to put this on the board.
All right.
There are two Nash Equilibria here.
One is all invest.
We'll invest and another one is,
okay.
No one invest.
All right.
These are both mashed Collibra in this game.
Let's just check that they are exactly the argument that that,
that Kate said that if everyone invests,
then no one would have any regrets.
Everyone's best response would be to invest and if nobody invests,
then everyone would be happy not to have invested.
That would be a best response.
It's just in terms of what Patrick said,
it is again,
with two equilibria like the previous game and that there are other similarities
to the previous game,
but it's a little bit of the,
in this case on not quite the same as the other game and the other game,
that other equilibrium,
there's zero zero equilibrium seemed like a silly equilibrium.
It doesn't like we'd ever predicted happening.
Whereas here,
the,
the equilibrium with nobody investing.
Right.
Actually it's quite a plausible equilibrium.
If,
if,
no,
if I think no one else is investing,
then I strictly preferred not to invest.
Is that right?
Okay.
So two remarks about this.
Uh,
I want to do more before I do it moves your remarks.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
what do you want?
Let's have one rock at least.
How do we find those Nash Equilibrium?
What was our sophisticated mathematical technique for finding the,
now she could have burned in this game.
So I should,
we should,
we should take it.
You can you get the mic on,
on,
uh,
is a,
she's k to that,
right?
Yeah.
So how did you find that actually collaborate?
Uh,
I looked for the only two places where,
um,
there's no regrets.
All right?
So,
so in principle,
you could have anything,
I mean that,
that works,
but in principle,
you could have looked at every possible combination and there's lots of possible
combinations.
It could have been a combination where 1% invested in 99% didn't and tubes and
invested in [inaudible] 98 didn't.
And so on so forth.
All right.
We could've checked rigorous way.
You want everyone's best response was in each case.
But what do we actually ended up doing in this game?
I the method.
Yeah.
Uh,
we got the guy in.
Yeah.
You only consider situations where your action can have a different outcome.
And those only occur when everyone's investing are known.
So that's true.
So that certainly makes it easier.
I claim,
however,
I mean,
you're being,
you're both of you being a more rigorous and more mathematical.
I'm tempted to be here.
I think the easy method here,
uh,
the easiest sophisticated math here is to,
is to guess.
All right?
My guess is the easy thing to do is just a guest.
What flight did have been equilibrium here and then what?
And then check.
All right,
so a good method here in these games
is the guests and check and getting check is really not a bad way to try and
find.
Actually Collibra.
The reason it's not a bad way is because checking is fairly easy,
right?
Guessing is hard.
You might miss something.
I might be an,
she could have been hidden under a stone somewhere.
All right?
And it's not state in America to rocket and hit on a rock somewhere.
Alright.
But checking,
that's something that you slap some Houston economy.
I'm trying to equilibrium checking whether it isn't equilibrium is easy,
cause I only have to do is check that nobody wants to move away.
They want us to deviate,
right?
So I think in practice that's what we're gonna end up doing in this game and it
out to be very easy to get some check,
which is why you're able to find it.
Right?
So guessing check is a very useful method in these games,
whether a lots and lots of players,
but not many strategies per player.
It works pretty well.
All right.
Okay,
now we've got this game up on the board.
I want to spend a while discussing x.
It's kind of important,
so I want to do now is order to remind ourselves what happened just now.
So what happened just now?
Can we,
can we raise the yeses again or they invest again and raised the non investors?
None of us.
And I want to remind you guys,
you all owe me 10 bucks.
All right?
All right.
I want,
I want to do is I want to play it again.
No communication right down again on the corner of your notepad.
What you're going to do,
brand communicates.
Don't communicate.
You guys.
All right?
Show your neighbor.
Yeah.
All right.
And now we're going to poll again.
So ready without,
without cheating,
without looking around you if you invested,
all right,
let,
let you get a good view of you.
If you invested,
raise your hand now
and if you didn't invest,
you didn't know.
Okay.
All right.
Can I look at the investors again?
Raise your hands on this way.
All right.
We've got a few investors still,
so these guys really owed me money now.
That's good.
All right.
All right,
let's do it again.
third time.
Third time.
Hang on a second.
Ten second.
So third time,
right down.
Write down.
I'm pretend this isn't real cash.
All right.
Now if you invested the third time,
raise your hand.
All right,
we've got it.
All right.
This is a few.
Soccer is born every day basically.
All right,
so where are we heading here?
Where are we heading?
Pretty rapidly,
right?
We're heading towards an equilibrium,
Just let's make sure we confirm that.
So everyone who didn't invest that third time raise your hands.
All right,
that's pretty close.
That show of hands is pretty close to a nash equilibrium strategy,
isn't that right?
Isn't that right?
So here's an example of a third reason when we already mentioned last time,
but a third reason why we might be interested in Nash Equilibria.
There are certain circumstances in which play converges in a natural science.
On the formal sense with a natural sense to an equilibrium.
Right?
And we work with the exception of a few dog,
good people who want to pay for my lunch.
Almost everyone else was converging to an equilibrium.
All right,
so play converged
fairly rapidly
to the nash equilibrium.
All right,
well,
we discussed it with two Nash Equilibria in this game.
Is one of these Nash Equilibria ignoring me for a second?
He's one of these natty collaborate better than the Aba.
Yeah.
Clearly the everyone investing Nash equilibrium is the better ones.
That right?
Everyone agree?
Everyone investing is a better nash equilibrium for everyone in the class than
everyone not investing.
Is that correct?
That's great.
Nevertheless,
where are we were converging in this case was what?
Where are we converging?
Was the bad equilibrium,
right?
We were converging rapidly to a very bad equilibrium.
I mean grandma,
which,
which no one gets him thing,
which all that money is left on the table.
All right,
so how can that be?
How do we converge to this bad?
He groomed to be a bit more formal.
The bad equilibrium,
the no invest equilibrium here is Perico dominated by the good equilibrium.
Everybody is strictly better off at the good equilibrium than at the body will
ever meet.
Perissa dominates.
Right?
To use an expression that you probably learned to one 15 or one 15.
Nevertheless,
we're going into the bad one.
We're heading to the bad equilibrium.
Why did we end up going to the bad equilibrium rather than the good equilibrium?
Yeah.
Uh,
can we get the guy in the gray?
Yeah.
Well it was a,
it was a bit of a bear market for investors,
wasn't it?
Just now?
You mean?
All right.
It's okay.
Say what you mean a bit more so yeah,
that's good.
Just say a bit more.
Um,
so it seemed like it seemed like people,
people didn't have a lot of confidence that,
um,
that other people were,
we're going to invest and so it became a successively,
um,
less desirable options.
Right.
All right.
So,
so one way of saying that was when we started out,
we were offering even whenever you're half,
half,
but that was already bad for the people who invested.
All right.
And then two until we started out at half,
half,
which was below that critical threshold of 90% is that right?
And from then on in we just tumbled down.
All right,
so one way to say this,
and I want you to think about that is it may matter in this case where we
started,
right?
Suppose the first time we played the game in this class this morning,
suppose that 93% of the class had invested,
in which case there's 93% would all have made money.
Right?
Now I'm I my guests is,
I can't prove this.
My guess is we might have converged the other way and converged up to the good
equilibrium.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
So people,
people figured out that they,
people who didn't invest the first time actually they played the bass response
to the class.
So they stayed put.
And those of you who didn't invest,
a lot of you started not investing as you got caught up in this spiral downward.
And we ended up not investing.
But how do we start it off above the critical threshold?
The threshold here is 90% and had you made money the first time around,
then it would have been the non investors that would have regretted that choice
and they might've switched into investing and we might,
I'm not saying we necessarily,
but we might have gone the other way.
Yeah.
Let me,
I'm gonna make them
30 70 thing where 70% invested.
So that's a good question too.
Suppose we'd been close to the threshold but below.
So I don't know is the answer.
I was thinking over didn't,
we didn't do the experiment,
but it seems likely that the higher,
the closer we got to the threshold,
the better chance there would have been going up.
My guess is,
is this the guest?
My guest is,
if we started below the threshold,
we'd probably have come down and we started above the threshold would probably
have gone up.
But that's not a theorem.
I'm just,
I'm just speculating on what might've happened.
Speculating on your speculations.
Alright,
so here we have a game with two equilibria.
One is good,
one is bad,
one is really quite bad.
It's prey to dominated.
All right.
And notice that what happened here,
the way we,
the way we spiraled down coincides with something we've talked about now.
She put them already.
It coincides with this idea of a self fulfilling prediction as self fulfilling
prediction provided you think other people are not going to invest,
you're not going to invest,
so it's a self fulfilling prediction to take you down to not investing.
Conversely,
provided everyone thinks everyone else is going to invest,
then you're going to go up to the good equilibrium and I think corresponds to
what the gentleman said in the middle about a bear market versus a bull,
right?
It was a bear market.
It looked like everyone else didn't have confidence in everyone else's and
fasting and then that was a self fulfilling prophecy and we ended up with no
investment.
All right.
Okay.
Now we've seen the bad outcomes in the class before.
For example,
the very first day we saw a prisoner's dilemma,
right?
But I claim that though were getting a bad outcome here in the class.
This is not a prisoner's dilemma,
right?
Why is this not a prisoner's dilemma?
What's different between both games have an equilibrium,
which is bad prisoner's dilemma and has the bad equilibrium where nobody tide is
there room on both guys go to jail.
But I claim that is not a prisoner's dilemma that [inaudible] to behind you.
No one suffers,
but no one gets any fun in this.
Okay.
So maybe they don't come isn't quite so bad.
That's fair enough.
I could have made it worse.
Right?
You could've made it sort of,
uh,
you know,
um,
I could have made that.
I could have lowered the payoffs some type of a pretty bad what,
why else is this another person in that the woman who's behind him that matter
because there's no strictly dominant strategy.
Good,
good.
So prisoner's dilemma playing Alpha was always a best response.
What led us to the bad outcome and prisoner's dilemma was the Alpha,
the,
the uh,
the defense strategy,
the,
the non corporate strategy.
Then not helping tidy your room strategy was always the best thing to do here.
And sometimes the good thing,
the moral thing in some sense is to invest.
But it's not the case that not investing dominates investing.
In fact of all the people invest in the room,
you want to invest.
Is that right?
All right.
So this is,
this is,
this is a social problem,
but it's not a social problem of the form of a prisoner's dilemma.
All right,
so what kind of problem is this
kind of social problem?
Is this say the guy in front of you?
Perhaps this one of a cooperation.
It's one of,
okay.
So it's,
it would help if people cooperate.
Did he here,
but I'm looking for a different times.
I turned the,
came up the first bay
coordination.
This is a coordination game.
Yes.
Hello?
People who read the New Yorker.
I'm a lot over the second day.
It's a coordination.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So
why is it a coordination game?
Because you like everyone in the class to coordinate their responses on invest.
All right.
And in fact,
if they did that,
they'd ever be happy.
Right?
And no one would have an incentive to the fact that would not be in equilibrium.
But unfortunately,
quite often we fail to have coordination either.
Either ever one of them.
This is the iPhone coronation.
I either everyone pays not invest or has happened the first time in the class we
get some split with people losing money.
All right,
so I claim that actually this is not a rare thing into science at all.
There are lots of coordination problems in society.
There are lots of things that look like coordination games and often in
coordination games,
bad results and I want to spend,
most of us are today talking about that cause I think it's important.
All right,
wherever you are,
whether you're an economist or whatever,
so let's talk about it,
about what else has the structure of a coordination game and therefore can have
the outcome that people can be uncoordinated or can coordinate it in the wrong
place and you end up in a bad equilibrium.
What else has what else looks like there's let's,
let's collect some ideas here,
but know how I got to handle way at the back motor.
You can get the guy who was just way,
way,
way at the back.
Right up against the,
yeah,
there you go.
Great.
Thank you.
Wait for the Mike gets to then.
Yeah.
Oh,
like a party on campus can be a coordination game.
Yeah.
Good,
good.
Okay.
So podium campus is a coordination game because what,
because you have to coordinate a being at the same place.
Is that right?
That's the idea you had.
You had,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
The thing is like if,
uh,
if not very many people are coming,
the people that did come are not going to enjoy it.
But if a lot of people do come,
then it will be good for everybody.
Good,
good,
good.
Okay.
That's,
that's good.
That's good.
So that's another way in which there's two ways in which a party can be,
it can be a coordination problem.
One is the problem that people don't show up.
It's a lousy parties who don't want to show up.
Conversive everyone's showing up.
It's great.
It's a lot of fun.
It's the place to be and everyone wants to show up.
And second,
so there's two equilibria they're showing up on everyone,
not showing up.
What everyone showing up.
And a similar idea,
uh,
the location of parties where I was put your driving habits is this similar idea
can can occur.
So it used to be the case in new haven that there are different,
there's not many anymore,
but they used to be different balls around campus,
none of which you're allowed to go to.
So you don't know about.
But anyway,
lots of different balls on campus and there's a coordination game where people
coordinate on Friday night or to be more honest for graduate students,
typically Thursday night.
All right.
So it used to be the case that one of those bars downtown was where the drama
school people coordinated.
And another one was where the economists coordinated and it was pretty good
equilibrium,
but they didn't coordinate at the same place.
All right.
So one of these you have to learn when you go to a new town is where is the
meeting point for,
for,
for the kind of party I want to go to.
And again,
you can have a failure of coordination.
Everyone's wondering around the town getting mugged.
All right.
One of the things like coordination problems like that.
So again,
way back in the corner that matter,
there's somebody right behind you.
There you go.
You have to really shout out,
um,
maybe warring parties in a civil war signing a treaty.
Okay.
That could be,
so I'm,
I'm,
I couldn't be a coordination problem.
It has,
it has a feeling of being a bit prisoner's dilemma aeration.
Some sense as long as my disarming my putting down my arms before you put in
your arms,
that kind of thing.
So it could be a coordination problem,
but he has a little bit of a flavor of both.
[inaudible] go ahead.
Go ahead.
Go ahead,
go on.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll the other examples.
This is the guy that one or that when you get the guy who behind you that I'm
going to get by the door.
They get great at a sports arena.
People deciding whether or not they want to start a chant for whatever team.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not quite sure which is the good outcome or the bad outcome.
So there's this thing called the wave.
There's a single,
the way that Americans insist on doing and I guess they think that's the good
outcome.
All right.
Other things?
Where did they go?
See?
Yeah.
Good.
Let's come back to that one.
Just hold that thought.
We'll come back to it next time.
But you're right.
That's a good,
that's great.
Let's come back to it next time.
All right,
and anything else?
Anything else?
Let me try and let me try and expand on some of these meeting place ideas.
We try Tyler pubs to meet saddle parties to meet at.
But think about online sites,
online sites,
which are chat sites or dating sites or whatever.
Right?
Those are,
there's online sites.
Uh,
clearly you have the same feature of party,
right?
You want people to coordinate on the,
on the same site.
All right.
Well what about some other economic ideas?
The ideas from economics.
What else has that kind of externality?
They can like a meeting place.
A,
yeah.
Yeah.
Can Get,
can we get him that patch right there?
I mean it's excluding some people,
but things like newspapers or something like we want my one,
only one,
like global news site.
So that's an interesting thought because it can go both ways.
It could be a bad thing.
I did have one newspaper for obvious reasons,
but in terms of having a good conversation about what was in the newspaper
yesterday around the,
around the uh,
uh,
over lunch,
it helps everyone.
Fred,
the same thing.
And certainly there's a bandwagon effect this with TV shows.
If everybody in America watches the same TV show,
which apparently is American idol these days,
then you can all talk about it over lunch notice.
That's a really horrible place to coordinate.
Alright.
There are similar examples to the American idol example.
When I was growing up in England,
I again,
I'm going to reveal my age.
Uh,
everybody decided that to be an in person in England,
you had to wear flared trousers,
right?
Right.
This was,
and so to be in you have to wear flat trousers.
This is the horrible coordination problem,
right?
So for people who don't believe that could ever happen to them and you could
ever have these sort of fashion goods that you end up at a horrible equilibrium
at the wrong place.
You believe that could ever happen.
Think about the entirety of the Midwest,
right?
I didn't say that.
We're going to cut that off the film later.
All right.
What else is like this?
What else is getting a few ideas on?
How do I get this?
It's got this dumped on my head.
The establishment of monopolies,
like say like because like a lot of people use Microsoft save and then
everything is compatible with Microsoft so more people want to use it.
Good.
So that,
sorry,
I've forgotten your name sir.
Stephen.
Stephen's pointing out that certain software can,
can act this way by being a network.
Good.
The more people who use Microsoft and Microsoft programs,
the bigger the advantage to me using Microsoft.
All right.
And therefore cause I can exchange programs,
I can exchange files if I'm working with my coworkers and so on.
And so you can have different equilibria coordinating on different,
and again,
you could end up at the wrong one.
I think a lot of people would argue,
but I'm gonna stay neutral on this.
A lot of people would argue that Microsoft wasn't necessarily the best place for
the world to end up.
All right?
There are other technological network goods like this.
These are called network externalities.
And example here would be high definition television,
right?
You want to have one technological standard that everyone agrees on.
Five things like high definition televisions because then everyone can produce a
TV to that standard and,
and uh,
good that go along with that standard.
And of course it matters each,
each company who's producing a TV and has a standard mind,
we'd like this to be chosen as the standard.
And again,
you could end up at the wrong place.
You could end up in a bag bringing back,
all right,
political bandwagons right?
In politics,
particularly in primary is there may be an advantage.
I am on the democratic side,
on the Republican side in having you all vote for the same candidate in the
primary.
So they get this big boost and it doesn't seem like your party split and so on.
Right.
And that could end up,
and again,
I'm gonna just run neutral on this.
It just could end up with the wrong candidate winning.
Right?
There's a political bandwagon affects the person who wins New Hampshire and Iowa
tends then to win everything.
All right.
So that's another example.
Any other,
uh,
economic examples?
Yeah,
there's,
uh,
can we get,
can we get this guy in here
listing on a Scot?
A Stock Exchange?
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
so in particular in particular,
which stock exchange to list on it?
Right.
So,
so there's,
there's a huge advantage in having lots of stocks on the Stock Exchange.
There are shared fixed cost.
There's also liquidity issues,
all right.
And lots of issues that,
uh,
of that form of mostly mostly the form of fixed costs.
So there's a tendency to end up with one stock exchange.
We're not there yet,
but we do some be going that way quite rapidly.
Right?
The problem,
of course being that might not be the best doc exchange or it might get that
stock exchange.
Monopoly power.
All right,
let me get one more.
Let me throw out one more example.
What about bank runs?
What's a bank run?
What's a bankrupt somebody,
uh,
yeah.
Can we get this guy?
What's the bank bankrupt?
Um,
it's when,
when,
uh,
when the,
when the public loses confidence in this,
their security of their money in banks,
then they rushed to,
to withdraw the deposits.
Okay.
So you imagine a bank as natural case where there's two equilibria,
there's a good equilibrium,
everyone has confidence in the bank,
everyone leaves their deposit in the bank.
The bank is then able to lend some of that money out and earn a higher rate of
interest on it.
The bank doesn't want to keep all those,
all that money locked up in the vault.
It wants about lended out to lenders who can pay and trust.
Right.
That's a good,
that's a good equilibrium for everybody.
However,
if people lose confidence in the bank and start drawing their deposits out,
then the bank hasn't got enough cash and it's vault to cover those deposits and
the bank goes under.
All right.
Now,
I used to say at this point in the class,
none of you would've seen a bank cron because they stopped happening in America
more or less around 19,
in the mid thirties.
There were lots and lots of bank crumbs in America before the 1930s.
But since,
uh,
federal deposit insurance came in this far fewer.
However,
I really can't say that today because there's a main crime going on right now.
Right?
There's a bank going on actually in England with a company called northern
security at know northern rockets called northern rock as we speak,
right?
And it's really is a bankroll.
I mean,
it,
uh,
if you,
if you looked at the newspaper yesterday on the New York Times,
you'll see a line of depositers lined up outside the office is in London at this
bank trying to get their deposits out.
And you see the Bank of England trying to intervene to restore confidence.
And just to be clear,
this isn't simple.
This isn't a simple case of being about the mortgage crisis.
This bank does do mortgages,
but it doesn't seem to be particularly involved in the kind of mortgages that
have been at attracting all the publicity.
It really seems to be a shift in confidence.
They move from the good equilibrium I've ever wanted.
Remaining invested to the bad equilibrium I've ever won.
I'm taking their money out.
Hang on a second.
Okay.
No,
there are famous bank runs in American culture.
What's just in the movies anyway?
What is the famous bank?
Chronic in the movies,
in American movies.
It's a wonderful life.
All right.
There's actually,
there's one in Mary Poppins as well,
but we'll do,
it's a wonderful life.
How many of you have seen it's a wonderful life?
I don't even not seen.
It's wonderful.
Like earlier poll here.
How many will not send them?
Okay,
keep your hand on a second here.
Hands up.
You need to do,
you need to know that if you're a green card,
you can lose your green card if you haven't tuned into one.
Okay.
Alright.
So in,
it's a wonderful life.
There's a run on the bank.
Actually it's a saving and loan,
but that never mind.
We'll think of it as bank.
All right?
And Luckily,
uh,
it doesn't end up with this saving and loan or bank going under.
Why doesn't the bank go under in it's a wonderful life.
Why doesn't it go on there?
Yeah,
the guy in blue and green.
Green.
Yup.
Um,
everyone agrees to only take as much as they need and not to take out their
whole entire deposit.
All right.
[inaudible] everyone agrees only to take out a small amount of hops,
even nothing.
Uh,
and therefore the banker on ends,
everyone rose at the bank isn't going to collapse and they're happy to leave
their money in the bank.
Now it's true.
Everyone agrees.
But why do they agree?
What makes them agree?
What makes them agree is Jimmy Stewart,
right?
Right.
Everyone remember the movie,
right?
So Jimmy Stewart gets up there and he says he gives a speech and he says,
look,
more or less,
I mean,
doesn't it in these words,
but he would've done even taken the class.
It says,
look,
there are two equilibria in this game.
I can't do the whatever it is,
west Pennsylvania accident ever does it that way.
It's fun anyway,
but I,
there are two grammar in this game.
There's a bad one,
will be all dry money out and we all lose our homes eventually.
And there's a good one when we all leave our money in and that's better for
everyone.
So let's all leave our money yet.
But he gives this,
he's a bit more motivationally stimulating than me,
right?
But he leads to people not leaving their money here.
So what I want to do is I want to pick on somebody in the class.
Now everyone has to understand this game.
Everyone just download this to equilibriate.
Everyone understands that when equilibriums better,
let's play the game again.
It's choose the game again.
But before I do,
I'm going to give the mic to Patrick here and Patrick is going to have,
uh,
exactly five seconds to persuade you.
Get sent up some steps up projects and have five seconds to persuade you.
Well,
whatever you liked,
you could pick your AA starting now.
Okay.
So clearly.
If we all invest,
we'll all be better off so everyone should invest.
All right?
All right.
Now let's see.
This is going to work.
Okay,
so let's see what happens on everybody.
Everybody,
oh,
we ain't got time to write down.
Everyone is going to invest.
Raise their hands.
Everyone's going to best raise their hands and everyone is not investing.
Raise their hand.
Oh wait,
we almost made it.
We must've almost made it.
All right,
so notice what happened.
I get a little right across a pattern or you did a good job back.
[inaudible]
but,
but there's a lesson here.
The lesson here is the game didn't change.
It's the same game that we've played three times already.
This was the fourth time we played it.
We had a totally different response in playing this time,
right?
Right.
Almost all of you,
the vast majority of you have.
Even 90% of you invested this time,
right?
And you did do in response to Patrick,
but Patrick wasn't putting any money down.
He wasn't bribing you.
He wasn't writing a contract with you.
He wasn't threatening to break your legs.
He just was pointing out.
It's a good idea.
Right?
Now,
remember the prisoner's dilemma in the prisoner's dilemma,
if Patrick,
Patrick would've got up in the prisoner's dilemma and given the same speech and
said,
look guys,
we're all better off if we choose Beta in the prisoner's dilemma then if we
choose Alpha Brian,
roughly the same speech.
And what would you have done in the prisoner's dilemma you'd have all chosen now
for anyway,
right?
So Patrick trying to persuade you or Patrick communicating to you that you do
better by choosing beats and the prisoner's dilemma doesn't work,
but here don't,
don't,
don't go yet.
Here does work.
Why does Patrick,
why is Patrick persuasive in this game?
But he isn't persuasive in the prisoner's dilemma.
Yeah.
Can we get the mic on Katie again?
Yup.
Why is Patrick was wasted in this game and not before.
He's not trying to persuade us to play a strictly dominated strategy.
He's not trying to get you to play a strip.
A common strategy and more than that,
he's played a bit swayed you to play was to play in Nash Equilibrium.
Alright?
So there's a lesson here in coordination problems.
Unlike prisoner's dilemma,
unlike prisoner's dilemma,
communication,
just communication,
no contracts,
communication kind of hell.
And in particular what we can persuade each other to do is to play the other
Nash Equilibrium.
And this gives us one more motivation for a nash equilibrium in a president's
dilemma.
To get out of it,
we needed a contract,
we needed side payments,
we needed to change the payoffs of the game.
But a nationally poor Librium can be a self enforcing agreement.
The Nash equilibrium can be self enforcing.
Yeah.
Agreements.
We can agree that we're going to play,
invest in this game,
and indeed we will play invest without any side payments,
without anybody threatening to break correct with any contracts,
without any regulation or the law.
I'm assuming Patrick,
isn't that Long Island?
All right,
we're going to end up doing the right thing here because it didn't our own
interest to do so.
All right,
so coordination problems,
which we've,
I think we've agreed are all over society when it comes to bank runs or bubbles
and all that,
that bubble's in the market or fashion in the Midwest.
They're all over society.
Communication can make a difference and we'll pick that theme up on Monday.